the city of San Francisco has cleaned
the streets homeless encampments have
been forcibly moved out of sight the
place looks presentable again even
livable if you can believe it and
residents of the city are completely
stunned they had no idea that anything
like this was possible Public Works is
installing decorative crosswalks in
North Beach and Chinatown and the
Webster Street pedestrian bridge in
Japan toown was recently repainted the
ybab bua Gardens at the Moscone Center
are decked out with new colorful
landscaping and murals paid for by the
clean California Grant just in time for
the 20,000 high-profile CEOs and heads
of state coming into town next week some
people say this should be how it's
always done what about the people who
are here year round you know in like
local hardworking workingclass Bay Area
folks that's a good question from that
guy why exactly doesn't the city of San
Francisco do this all the time